amen tim are you
king no i'm sorry but uh the problem is
not i just needed to know because i
needed to know if i'm not the only
atheist in the room no i'm not an
atheist no i never said you were a pet
i'm just saying so you you're the only
atheist in the room i am the only
atheist i'm not a man timothy pet
hold on let me qualify let me qualify
let me qualify now that now that tim and
i are friends we're friends um
i i for elijah can again call like can
again qualify this i say pet all the
time and it freaks americans out because
they're like why are you calling me a
pet and i'm like i'm not it's just part
of my speech what am i a cow
peter are you an atheist you're not no
i'm more agnostic than anything i mean
that cosmic microwave background
radiation is like the permeating
radiation left over from the big bang
looks like it's interacting with matter
and causing god that's the experience of
that interaction as god seems like it
but i believe that this christ
consciousness is real that it can
permeate this like
i don't know what it is like a spirit of
goodness i know good and evil are
subjective but because the holy spirit
the spirit of god is over the earth and
a lot of people mock me for my belief in
god but it's not just a consciousness
like christ is a real person but he's
also god and what's interesting is that
and this is where i know people who are
not christian would not believe this but
the only thing that is holding evil back
is the spirit of god that is currently
on the earth in those that are chosen
and there's going to be a rapture and
that one time that's why the end of the
world comes he pulls the spirit off the
face of the earth it's true and actually
evil continues we have the antichrist
things happen so this is why it's weird
how the bible
it says what the world would be like in
the end times and it describes what it
it would be like and it looks like the
world today it also says that there
would be the sharing of knowledge this
increase rapid sharing of of knowledge
around the world and a one-world economy
that it would create a one-world economy
a global economy and a one-world
government would be their goal where you
had to have some sort of a market
yeah where you had to have some sort of
buyer to sell right and that was like
it's very interesting the mark of the
business about the end times says that
you cannot buy sell or trade unless you
bear the mark and when i first heard
that i was a super chat on this show i
was like that that's too specific
talking about free market
restrictions what do you mean and then i
i looked it up yeah it literally says
you can't buy something right it's
possible but i i have to ask a question
on that um you're saying the only thing
holding evil back is is the spirit is is
the holy spirit the holy spirit who's
well so does that mean to imply that
like god put the evil here on purpose no
it's not that god put the evil here on
purpose but what vibrated the evil and
the evil no no so what so what's
interesting is is that if you look at
actually christian theology or what
actually happened is lucifer the devil
that we call the devil or satan is
actually an angel right all demons are
fallen angels and part of why god is not
a slave master but he's a just and a
fair god as he gives you
free will or the right to serve him or
to not and he is perfect and so what
happened was is that lucifer became i
could say jealous but he thought that he
was he was the best of all the angels
right he's most beautiful most talented
he was ahead of all of the music and
that he actually rebelled against god
and he thought that he could be god like
god and so it's kind of interesting even
how sin was brought into the world but
he was cast out of heaven many believe
that means that he was sent down to
earth and that's why there's that big
crater down in uh down in the gulf but
anyway a lot of people believe that but
i don't know how that's how that's yeah
i don't know if that's true but i will
say that he was cast down and what's
interesting is that it talks about that
some of these demons actually were so
evil and after they revolted and
separated themselves from god that some
of them are even like locked in chains
at the bottom of like the euphrates
river and they're held back and that
when the holy spirit leaves that the
evil is finally unleashed on the earth
that full evil is unleashed the reason
why the good keeps winning and the
reason why like evil never fully is able
to triumph and indefinitely take over is
because the holy spirit of god is
continually on the face of the earth and
is holding evil back but there's a
moment where god gives us what we want
and what people want like how aussies
want they want the government eventually
you really talk to them but most aussies
like they think what the government's
doing is good i mean that's really what
they say at least they think it's okay
yeah they're not like
what humans want is to not have to deal
with god and then god gives us that he
goes okay
have yourself and that's why the
antichrist is able to rise up and that's
it's so weird to me though that a bunch
of you know i'm saying this
sarcastically for people who can't
understand that
but a bunch of crazy fishermen liars you
know thousands of years ago somehow
predicted that what the end times would
look like is that people would be liars
they would claim to have the fear of god
but not express its power that they
would hate their families families would
be divided against themselves that they
would be backstabbers it talked about
they'd be greedy lovers of themselves uh
haters of god mockers of god and that
the key factors would that there would
be pestilence earthquakes and these
would be signs of the times and the goal
would be the spirit of the antichrist
would be to create a one world economy
and a one world government and that if
you that being an allegiance to that
government was part of the the uh
you had in order to like buy sell trade
to live you had to give your allegiance
to that leader who would take over and
declare himself god and it even it even
predicted the rebuilding of of and it
says that we'll know who he is because
he's going to sit he's going to rebuild
the temple on the temple mount uh where
he's going to rebuild the temple after
it's destroyed and he's going to sit on
the throne and declare himself god and
he says that israel was going to reform
as a nation and that it's like funny
they predicted that israel was going to
reform and it did and then they already
have the plans in place right now and
the materials to rebuild the new temple
and they're waiting for the right moment
so it's like it's crazy that like if
it's not real how they got so much of it
right or they read it and said hey let's
do that
that's possible too but i mean yeah yeah
that could that could be but you know i
wonder i'm not such a yep that's just a
really good explanation no i'm saying
that could that could be but they also
don't believe in the new testament the
jews don't even believe in in that as
well so they don't they don't follow
that no i don't i don't think it's any
one particular group i'm saying like if
you're saying that zionists don't
believe in the new testament if there is
a group of like you know global special
interests who are doing the things as
predicted it could just be those global
special interests are like hey i read
this book you read it hey there's a
bunch of good ideas for how we should
control the world i don't think they're
they really respect why well then why
would they just randomly follow
revelation random follow anything i'm
saying they're deliberately doing it i
mean it doesn't give you the plans on
how to carry it out
these are the signs they're too vague to
actually give you a way to carry it out
and then why would you choose that book
i mean it just if you look at it
statistically probably improbable
i think that
let me ask
when do you think the the the so it's
happening now right i think we're i
think we're in the the last days yeah i
think we're in the end times how much
time do we have i says no man knows the
day or the hour that's part of the
reason because it says that you know
what's crazy is it says that when these
things are coming to an end when god
comes to rapture his people
but there's no rapture is not mentioned
he says that it'll be caught up yes it
is it says it'll be caught up and it has
the word rapture is not
that's an english word an american word
yes so i'm saying that it says being
caught taken off so what it actually
talks about is very interesting because
this happened with with enoch and other
people in the bible but what is really
really interesting about this i'm saying
is that it categorizes this idea it's
it's very interesting it even like kind
of like predicts the theory of evolution
and whatnot that it says that that
during this time people are going to be
mocking god because it says they're
going to be buying and selling in trade
being given in marriage and living life
as it is saying that life has always
been and it always will be that there
was never this that it's been going for
a long time and it's going to continue
to evolve and continue to move on the
way that it's been and people are just
going to be it's going to be caught up
in their own lives in their own sin in
their own focus and then what god's
going to come back to judge the world
and it's going to catch them off guard
it's like a thief in the night that he's
going to come back and it's going to
throw everybody off and that's like kind
of crazy because even with covet it's
like you're just living and buying and
selling and trading and living life then
all of a sudden the world changes and we
see that where things just change in an
instant i know you guys don't believe it
but that's
what i saw this movie and i guess you
know spoiler alert for anybody who wants
to see the movie antidote i saw it on
amazon is actually pretty good so uh
well i'm just giving everybody a spoiler
warning give him a few more seconds for
us to catch up and then realize if you
want to see the movie it is uh about a
woman who wakes up in a hospital
where they torture people but then give
them a healing serum to regenerate them
and then continue doing experiments on
them
and so they do things where they cut
their eyes out or cut out their tongue
or impale them and then heal them and
then keep doing it cut their legs off
and uh spoiler warning for anybody who
wants to see it because it actually is a
pretty good movie
all right here we go
uh it actually turns out and i caught
this immediately so maybe it's not a
spoiler she the main character wakes up
in her bed and she's like something's
wrong like my stomach hurts and her
husband rushes her to the hospital and
then she has to go for a uh you know
she's appendicitis what's it called
epidectomy and then really hurts just by
the way so they they give her the
anesthetic she goes out they go in
surgery and then she wakes up in this
hospital where she's in a different room
it's a different doctor and her scar is
healed she can still see the scar but
it's mostly healed she's like how long
have i been here and i immediately said
she's dead she's in hell
and so i guess the idea of the movie is
that she's in the layer of level of hell
where they torture you and then heal you
and then torture you over and over again
for eternity and the story was that she
used to be a drug addict and she was
dating this guy who was abusing her and
then one day when he was abusing her she
grabbed something and swung it at him
and slashed his throat accidentally
killing him and then strung him up with
piano wire to get away with the crime
and she was condemned to an eternity of
being tortured literally in eternity and
i'm like
man if that's that's really messed up
like this idea of of you know
you you're defending yourself and you
accidentally kill somebody and then you
panic and now you have to literally go
to this hell where you get your legs
chopped off you get stabbed in the chest
they cut your face off and so i think
about stuff like that and i'm like if
god after everything we've seen with all
the evil and and the power of the evil
to manipulate and lie cheat and steal
and trick people and all that for god to
come down and be like i'm judging
everybody and these good people of good
conscience and ethics who didn't worship
me and didn't have faith in me yeah
you're all going to go to hell too even
though it was the evil that tricked you
but didn't you say about cops that
they're they're not good if they don't
quit based on those things so meaning
like how are what defines being a good
person
than if god
defines what that none of us are good no
not one because we were born into sin so
he said that the only way to be to
actually become and find redemption is
through the faith in the work of christ
so what happens to the non-believers
when the rapture happens
well not everyone believes not even
everyone believes in that the rapture is
but let's just say in your in your view
like god will come to judge everybody i
think that a lot of people will wake up
because i believe that a lot of people
are familiar with this and they will
realize because the bible talks about
that a lot of people refuse to get the
mark and the the punishment is beheading
they actually get beheaded in the
guillotine style thing they get their
heads chopped off if you don't submit to
the one world government and that's
because you're seen as an enemy because
even though you're just not buying
selling and trading you're a threat like
a terror threat all right so what's
going to happen so i'm saying that it
seems that it seems that a lot of people
get killed that a lot of people who
appear i would assume of good conscience
realize
oh crap that was right and that they
become they give their lives to god
that's what it seems like so what i'm
saying is there's obviously going to be
a lot of people
who are problems who are good people in
that they uh uh you know so i'll use my
look i believe in god but i don't
believe in christian theology so you
know
would i be condemned to hell because i'm
like yeah it's about because kezia um
she and i have conversations about this
all the time elijah's wife um because
she's you know very christian as well
and the way that she's described it to
me is that it's not necessarily about
your it's actually it is actually about
whether or not you fully actually
believe in god it's not about your good
works it's not about um any of that sort
of stuff it's about whether or not you
effectively like let him into your life
but the good works would follow so it's
kind of like sure sure i could say i'm a
car but it doesn't make me when i can
make the noise in the sounds but it
doesn't make me a car like yeah you
could say like oh i do believe in god
but of faith like you mentioned if you
believed in god and you would get to
know his heart that that should that
would transform you and that you would
become more like god you would see this
with a lot of people who genuinely have
real conversion and they become
christians that there's a radical change
in there so i don't i don't i don't who
are hypocrites though i'm a christian
but who don't actually
they're not actually christian if you
know what i mean like and i'm not here
to judge anybody because what the hell
do i know because i'm not religious why
would i
you know pledge anything to to an entity
that would condemn sydney to hell
well he's not condemning sitting in hell
sydney's choosing to go
right
but also i mean by the way so like doing
to eternally torture and cause suffering
for someone
but it's not based out of ignorance
because actually sydney's smarter than
me so so this is the point this is the
point i think he's actually hyper
intelligent i don't think sydney i don't
think sydney's stupid and i actually
used to be agnostic i've said that i
used to be agnostic um
you know i didn't really know what i
believed um but i but i did know that
it's what's interesting about this is is
that this is also beyond just the
physical that there is an actual such
thing as the spirit of a person of a man
and that these things that's why we
could be immoral or moral versus dogs
are instinctual right these are animals
they don't they don't have the soul this
is what this is distinctional eyes about
sentience about the person of who i am
as a human being this makes me sacred
and special god designed me in his image
and so someone like sydney sydney is not
dumb and i thoroughly and fully believe
that when i met sidney she was an
atheist now she's agnostic who knows
where she's headed now um but i do
believe that for instance god put us in
our lines together thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to see the full show
come back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments and
super chat and we actually will read
your comments on the show don't forget
to like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time
you